[Music]
in 3 2
action so good good good
[Music]
good you love bad name anyone but him I
didn't approve him you know that you are
literally the last person on Earth I
want to see slap the [__] out of you I
really could and I'm open to that in a
safer
[Music]
environment you been a ghost no phone
call no
text it's not like I didn't want to
apologize you don't have to explain
anything it was just a
flame so how have you
been God I hate that thumbs up stunky
stuff I'm the director we're going to
set this man on fire you're a stunk guy
we need to keep it super profes profess
is my middle name he said your middle
name was
danger how do we do
boss really yeah holster that it's
Holsted it's done forget you you never
saw
it Tom
Ryder the biggest action star on the
planet is missing you need to bring him
back B J's movie is dead why me you're a
stump man nobody's going to notice you
that's your job no offense I'm mean some
taken you find Ryder save Jody's film
you get the love of your life back I'm
not the hero I'm just a double not today
you're
not Tom we only need you back on set
pal oh
dead body on Ice he was so dead Gail he
was super
dead he has got himself involved with
some shady
people I had no choice I had to do some
Jason boor
[__] they were trying to kill
me and not in a fun way you making
you you can't make it it's too dangerous
got me
stairs
what happened to your face you look
terrible you look
amazing you fall down you get right back
up how far would you go for the one that
you
love I'll BL you drink when this is over
engage your
core yeah
boy what you doing later want to go to a
beach somewhere drink a spicy Margarita
make some bad decisions yes
oh sh to the heart and you're to
[Applause]
[Music]
blame